potremmo fare lo sponsor magliette space
perché siamo amici di nelson e tonno e
basta no sto scherzando
e anche se in realtà siamo amici
in italia tutto allora ci siamo su
preferiresti che da un sacco di tempo
che non facciamo io il buongiorno
per chi non lo conoscesse preferiresti
non avete avuto una suite di youtube
fino adesso infatti boc brutalità per
niente c'è questo sito che ti mette due
scelte tu devi scegliere quale fare tra
queste due essere in grado di congelare
il tempo per un'ora ogni 24 ore
essere in grado di replicare una cosa al
giorno che scompare dopo 24 ore istituti
moltiplichi i soldi e sarebbe bellissimo
ragazzi questa fontana non mi sarei
obbligato anche congelare il tempo poi
quando ci sono cose di barche di
qualcosa tra bottiglie da brando rapisce
alle to congeli tempo è piscio nesci
quindi è buona anche starò a ieri al
1000 che ogni tipologia di registro
picchiati e seppe creare la giusta la
gente stupida talmente stupida non sa
niente quindi mangia sono resti umani
per reso la tua vita come ri e di fame
questo c'è il file chi sto il buffo sì
ne pensi
penso che qui la recensione sul buco mi
piace un sacco e samurai plus 6 coltello
che usa il vecchio è un coltello che più
tagli e pisa fila questa è la mia
recensione di del buco ottimo samurai
blues quattro su cinque lo sai sta
rispondendo senza senza il pieno fi
morendo di fame e ovviamente però
mangiare solo resti umani
non lo so il sapore hanno praticamente
sa di non essere in grado di provare
tristezza non essere in grado di provare
rabbia
aspetta aspetta parliamo un attimo a me
la tristezza mi ispira molto a livello
artistico 6 quei momenti in cui no no
poi però dai qualcuno ti ammazza il
familiare 6 accanto non riesce a provare
tristezza c'è la città di corsa non è
solamente incazzate no si no e se sei
tele di tristezza gli dai una sprangata
e beh secondo della mafia se uno è morto
per casa naturale dai la brasiliana al
palo sfoga artica mio allenatore
allora io no no no servendo grifondoro
ecco questo dovresti prendere così sotto
il tuo culo eccolo vedere molto bravo
quindi abbiamo già disposto inizio di
filse con ti lascerò finire termine di
false con alle è che fai a letto poi
magari converge tutti i giorni scorsi
nell'andare a lei mi sono alzato a letto
fatto colazione a letto ad un quesito
non li posso fare perché dopo mi stanco
e quindi devo andare non ne sono sicuro
ma se ti va di provare qualcosa di nuovo
ma una city si chiama favola della
buonanotte potrebbe interessarci ma
perché card
si ok
ecco favola della buonanotte
[Risate]
questo era necessario prima di averlo a
letto ti racconto una favola cominciamo
mentre l'unione dormiva in un ombroso
basco dei topi di campagna e giocavano
un po si arrampicavano si rincorrevano e
giocavano a nascondino
fino a che una dopo linea troppo sbadata
si scontrò con il corpo sdraiato del
leone leoni si sveglia di colpo e la
zuffa con la sua zampone nord come usi
disturbare e il capobastone queste shell
infine se dovessi vestirti regolarmente
in un modo preferiresti sim ha investito
dalla vita in su con pantaloni e scarpe
e ridicoli
lorenzo si va investito dalla vita in
giù col camice capelli ridicoli scarpe
pantaloni di dio bene comunque 66 dovuto
esatti 16 per i video è difficile di
fissino hai la pelle blu e la pelle
rossa e blu fare il costo di megamind la
mettiamo questa canzone e mettiamo a
cogliere che poi ce le copie del
trentino bravo giampiero bravo però
c'era quindi quale blu perdi il pollice
preferito vinto quel pollice preferirò
il 6 sul mio destro per rivivere le
correnti opere sulla tastiera il sito fa
la barra spaziatrice è vero che ha messo
a fare
e fastidi gli chiedono non puoi saltare
nei videogiochi perdere l'indice e il
medio della mano preferita
scusa ma questi due c'è 6 con queste tre
mani pollice inviato lì avere un bambino
non attraente avere un bambino belli con
la pelle bratelle più brillante minchia
shine al felice si è creato un bambino
ma tu chi sei
non mi vedo io il bambino due tracciati
salta edifici alti in un unico limite
divertiti velocemente come flash
no no salto salto a elio tresi e
bellissimo secca non mi palazzo
all'altro la gente non merita ipotetica
vivi una vita media e lasciati
dimenticare nel tempo entra nella storia
che qualcosa di terribile io l'ho già
fatto mostro di loch ness o sasquatch
sua scorge mi è sempre pensato chissà
scotch e l'input è ciò che mi chiamò
proprio diversi con veloso e del grosso
quindi vai da marco e della stessa cosa
loch ness notte appunto quindi lo cresce
a loch ness
scherza poi da lei dalle immagini che
alcala brass ha reagito che bello vai
trapiantare il tuo cervello in un robot
of a incrementare il tuo cervello nel
senso opposto
mica sono incredibili tutte però un
robot ma poiché cos'è che il robot 6
cioè sei semplicemente un essere umano
sia il posto del ai l'altro però da un
robot però puoi fare quello che vuoi
gli altri vogliono lo stesso opposto
nome cioè molti di più tra le banche
viene niente circle of life
le canzoni del re leone ogni volta che
scorretti ci va bene si può flai e fai
suonare il coro di thriller quando tutti
circle of line si è molto più volte
andrà a cena oppure quando entri in una
strana parte fondente in una stanza
parte di lavoro nazionale di darth vader
appena salda da ls ragazzi la
trattazione arrivato sia un vampiro che
può trasformarsi in una mazza sia un
fantasma che può possedere solo
elettrodomestici
mamma mia però idea di quanti 7 di
benedetta parodi sfancula resti
bellissimo quindi prendiamo il
frullatore bisogna sì stupido avere un
bambino geniale o sei brillanti a
bambino subito che c'è di così brillante
preferiresti vincere un oscar o vincere
il nobel per noi
immagino che muovo scarsi giustamente ci
sta a seconda che siano cinefili la
voglia infatti io ci hanno dato anche
vicino allora questa è l'ultima
preferiresti essere picchiato da un
bambino di 7 anni o picchiare un
settantasettenne allora io non picchiare
mai nessuno e preferirei essere
picchiato in realtà penso sarebbe
picchia però alla tradotto male quindi
io leggo che ha tradotto quindi io
voglio se io voglio essere picchiato da
un bambino se un bambino può tirarmi è
quello schiaffetto lo posso fare il
bambino si bambino se ai 7 anni secondo
questo video poi tirarmi un pugno no
scherzo non si usa non mai usare sempre
carezze non usate la violenza però non
picchiare anche 77 ma che domande sono
ben ringrazio dice ancora partecipato
questo video e noi ha proseguito
schiacciate mi piace e belle ragazze
[Musica]